bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 sur
TVfil 78 durant la prochaine heure nous
allons revenir en direct si vous nous
suivez à 18h sur l'actualité de ce 5
décembre à commencé par les 20 ans du
Centre d'histoire culturel des sociétés
contemporaines à l'université de
versaill Saint-Quentin en Yveline invité
pour en parler Jean-Claude Dion
directeur adjoint du centre bonsoir à
vous et merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
on verra en détail tout à l'heure vos
activités mais déjà le Centre d'histoire
culturelle des sociétés contemporaine ça
consiste en quoi quelles sont les études
que vous menez alors c'est un
laboratoire d'histoire culturelle
c'estàdire qu'on étudie l'histoire
sociale des représentations un
laboratoire donc d'histoire mais aussi
avec des littéraires avec des linguistes
qui cherchent à comprendre la société
depuis en fait le milieu du 18e siècle
jusqu'à nos jours et ce laboratoire fait
donc ces 20 ans on va en parler dans
quelques instants bonsoir également Joan
Bir comme tous les mercredis avec vous
nous allons faire le point sur la
culture la chronique culture dans un
petit quart d'heure oui nous irons à
coignère au théâtre Alphonse d'udet pour
nous intéresser à un spectacle qui va
être joué il s'appelle le voyage c'est
la pièce de comique de théâtre le voyage
de Monsieur Périchon à tout à l'heure
Jana donc dans une quinzaine de minutes
he pour cette chronique culture le reste
des titres en imag à présent les autres
sujets que nous allons aborder en ce 5
décembre c'est la journée mondiale du
bénévola les associations sont souvent
en recherche de bénévoles pour les aider
à les recruter une initiative originale
en speed dating a été organisé à
Versailles nous y reviendrons avec en
plateau notamment la déléguée
départementale à la vie associative des
ivelines 24h avant le début de la Star
Académie au château de la jeuneste à
château fort ce soir nous vous proposons
une visite guidée de cette bâtisse
ivelinoise donc les températures se
refroidissent les premiers flocons ont
fait leur apparition en fin d'après-midi
le département des Yvelines se tient
prêt le plan neige a été déclenché il
est en vigueur jusqu'au 17 mars et puis
toujours de saison la patinoire de
Versailles elle a repris du service une
patinoire écologique dotée d'une surface
synthétique et qui fonctionne sans zone
électricité installé devant l'hôtel de
ville jusqu'au 6 janvier le plan neige
reprend donc du service les premiers
flocons sont d'ailleurs tombé en fin
d'après-midi sur Saint-Quentin en
Yveline vous envoyez déjà quelques
images soyez vigilants bien sûr en
raison du Vergl ce plan neige qui a été
élaboré fin 2011 pour garantir
l'efficacité des opérations de salage en
de neige ou de verglas et donc à nouveau
en vigueur et ce je vous le disais jusau
17 mars afin d'éviter la de revivre la
pagaille de décembre 2010 les
explications tout de suite de Catherine
zulaton chacun se souvient des épisodes
neigeux de l'hiver 2010 et des
automobiliste bloqué en fin d'après-midi
la leçon a été retenue et depuis 2 ans
les services plus que mobilisés pendant
ces mois d'hivers un plan vigilance a
été mise en place dans le département
depuis quelques jours les équipes de
techniciens et cadres sont mobilisés en
astrain 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heur sur 24
cette année comme l'an passé les équipes
du département vont s'appuyer sur la
participation de 15 agriculteurs afin
d'être le plus réactif possible en zone
rurale comme urbaine pendant l'hiver
dernier le département a connu de forts
épisodes neigeux les équipes de la
Direction des routes et des transports
sont intervenu 104 fois et 1900 tonnes
de sel ont été utilisées dès les
premiers flocons de neige les usagers
pourront consulter les dernières alertes
de circulation ou de déig sur le site
internet du conseil général vous pouvez
aussi vous abonner avec votre
smartphone jean-claudeon est donc le
premier invité du 78 de ce soir maître
de conférenceabilité enseignant en
histoire je le disais au début de cette
professeur excusez-moi vous êtes
professeur depuis vous comme c'est
récent comme ça on donne l'information
vous avez tout à fait raison je le
disais le Centre d'histoire culturelle
des sociétés contemporaines de
l'Université de versaill Saint-Quentin
qui faitte ses 20 ans vous en êtes le
directeur adjoint et il a été fondé tout
juste après la création de l'université
de Versailles saqutin en Eveline ça veut
dire que l'histoire a un poids important
dans cette faculté oui parce qu'en fait
dans dans la dans l'histoire de
l'université au sein des sciences
humaines parce que aussi une histoire
des des sciences dures qui est plutôt du
côté de versaill le Département
d'histoire a été un des premiers fondés
au départ comme une annexe de dentaire
et c'est vrai que donc historiquementah
on est un des premiers à s'est installer
ici et voilà 20 ans déjà qu'on est là et
ce centre est le seul laboratoire
d'histoire en France ayant pour objet
exclusif la recherche en histoire
culturelle du contempor oui parce qu'en
fait on avait compris dès le départ et
ça a été le l'idée du créateur du centre
Pascal Ori qui depuis est parti est
professeur à la Sorbonne que pour notre
université et je crois que c'est valable
pour aussi d'autres matières pour lutter
contre les grandes faques parisiennes il
faut avoir un créneau bien précis dans
lequel on est un un renom d'excellence
qu'on a réussi à seonstru au fil des
années il faut pas lutter avec les
grandes fac en voulant être généraliste
mais avoir un type de recherche précis
et donc on a choisi l'histoire
culturelle parce que c'était le moment
où elle se développait maintenant elle
est un peu hégémonique et donc du coup
on bénéficie de ce choix qui a été fait
il y a 20 ans justement c'était
précurseur à l'époque quand vous avez
décidé de de lancer ce centre là ce
laboratoire ça s'est fait naturellement
ça a été difficile de le mettre en place
ça s'est fait un petit peu en mettant un
pied devant l'autre et et les choses se
sont faites ce qui est formidable à 550
an en ieline dans une ville nouvelle
c'est que justement on peut faire des
choses alors que le monde universitaire
quand même est souvent un peu sclérosé
un peu conservateur et là on arrive on
lance des séminaires on fait des coques
on lance des programmes de recherche et
les choses se font en partie d'ailleurs
aussi parce que la ville nouvelle a
toujours beaucoup soutenu l'université
alors les chercheurs étudient les usages
et les pratiques culturelles aussi les
sensibilités les valeurs les croyances
les imaginaires communs les normes et
les univers symbolique tout ça c'est sur
le papier concrètement ça consiste en
quoi quel type de recherche on pourrait
citer pour que le grand public comprenne
ce que vous faites alors on a des
domaines d'excellence qui sont par
exemple l'histoire du livre ou encore
l'histoire des médias et le le par
exemple il est sûr que que le le le
journal que vous faites en ce moment ça
peut devenir un un objet de recherche et
je pense que dans quelques années il y
aura peut-être un mémoire de Master
sur sur cette émission il y a aussi
l'histoire des spectacles dont je
meoccupe plus directement et puis aussi
l'histoire des relations culturelles
internationales finalement il y a
énormément de domaines l'histoire
culturelle c'est plus une sorte de
regard une façon de d'analyser les les
événements plutôt que des une spécialité
précise avec un domaine précis vous
parliez de l'histoire justement des
spectacles tout à l'heure sur ce plateau
nous parlons de la représentation du
voyage de Monsieur Pichon par exemple
deugenne Labiche qui sera joué du côté
de de coignère avec la compagnie
l'élixir ils seront sur ce plateau tout
à l'heure ça peut être un sujet d'étude
par exemple la façon dont aujourd'hui
s'est joué s'interprété par rapport voà
et puis même aussi ce qu' a été la pièce
au 19e siècle elle a été créée en 1860
et on a fait par exemple un colloc sur
les spectacles sous compte empire qu'on
avait tenu au théâtre de 5 en Eveline
donc vous voyez on cherche aussi à
sortir de la fac parce que on est sur
des domaines et des sujets qui peuvent
intéresser un public large et donc c'est
vrai quand on fait de la physique
quantique c'est entre spécialistes mais
là quand on parle de spectacle de
théâtre on cherche au maximum et on a
beaucoup l'appui des des structures
culturelles de la ville on cherche
effectivement à faire en sorte que le
public saintcantinois puisse suiv nos
travaux et puisse aussi avoir accès à
notre site internet qui est un élément
très important pour notre labo donc
c'est de l'histoire je pense accessible
à un large public oui pas uniquement
entre chercheurs pour les chercheurs pas
uniquement entre chercheurs voilà et
aussi quand même élément important c'est
qu'on a beaucoup de doctorants donc
beaucoup de jeunes chercheurs et ce
qu'on cherche aussi c'est à les lancer
dans dans la vie et dans la cité donc il
participe pleinement à la vie
5quantinoise justement ils sont
chercheurs ils vont être chercheurs tout
leur vie ensuite quelle branche vers
quelle branche ils s'orientent par
exemple alors on on a beaucoup de nos
étudiants qui deviennent professeur du
secondaire qui est avec peut-être
l'espoir ensuite de faire une carrière
dans le supérieur mais c'est vrai que
c'est des domaines un peu un peu fermé
et c'est pour ça aussi que le le centre
et plus généralement le Département
d'histoire a créé des masters
professionnels autour de la des archives
autour des métiers de la culture pour
donner des débouchés que la recherche ne
soit pas le seul débouché de ces
étudiants qui bien souvent ont commencé
en première année d'histoire chez nous
et qu'on accompagne finalement pendant
10 ans c'est le seul centre donc en
France quel est son poids en Europe voir
dans le monde vous échangez avec vos
homologues européens internation alors
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure qu' un des
aspects importants un des thèmes de
recherche c'était les relations
culturelles internationales et on
cherche effectivement à exister au au
niveau et on y arrive je pense assez
bien au niveau international par exemple
on a lancé un grand programme de
recherche sur la mondialisation de la
culture au 19e siècle avec le Brésil
donc on accueille des étudiants
brésiliens on va faire cours au Brésil
on a beaucoup de rapports aussi avec la
Chine avec différents pays européens on
a des spécialistes de l'Allemagne de
l'Est par exemple et c'est sûr que
maintenant un centre ne peut pas exister
de façon franco-française et de ce point
de vue là l'histoire culturelle c'est un
un bon billet pour pour voyager et pour
exporter le la recherche à la française
mais il y a une vraie reconnaissance
aussi ne serait-ce que sur le territoire
français alors par exemple vous êtes
classé le centre est classé à plus
laboratoire d'excellence par l'instance
nationonale d'évaluation de la recherche
alors oui ça c'est un petit peu les
affaires de cuisine interne des des
universités mais vous savez qu'on aime
beaucoup les classements maintenant et
Dieu merci c'est toujour une fté quand
on voilà c'est une fierté exactement
mais après il faut le défendre et puis
euh on l'a pour une certaine période il
faut continuer à le à le maintenir euh
de ce point de vue là aussi on est
partie prenante d'un d'un d'un Labex je
pense que nos spectateurs ont entendu ce
ce TER he c'est les les grands
programmes de recherche qui ont été
lancés par le précédent gouvernement
donc il y a un Lab s'appelle PATRIMA qui
est fait avec sergie autour du
patrimoine matériel et le centre comme
d'autres centres du du de l'université
et comme d'autres centres à sergis avec
des grandes institutions parisiennes
participe à ce Labex qui est une forme
de reconnaissance importante et le
centre qui fait donc ces 20 ans on va
parler des perspectives pour les 20
prochaines années mais comment il a
évolué déjà sur ces 20 premières années
ah bah il il a énormément évolué parce
que comme on était pionnier quand on est
pionnier le le but c'est de le rester et
donc c'est forcément de se renouveler et
puis il y a des arrivées des départs de
chercheurs qui amènent des inflexion je
pense que pour les 20 ans à venir
notamment ce qui est très important
c'est la présence du centre sur Internet
et par exemple dans quelques jours nous
allons ouvrir une base de données
bibliographique en histoire culturelle
et qui est accessible à tout le monde
pas simplement aux chercheurs mais à
l'ensemble des gens qui nous regardent
une base de données qu'on a voulu en
français en anglais et en espagnol
précisément pour avoir ce cette ce
rayonnement international et donc je
pense que beaucoup de choses qui se
feront à l'avenir se feront via l'outil
Internet et de ce point de vue-là le VSQ
est bien positionné on pourrait y
trouver quoi par exemple sur cette base
de données quels éléments on pourra y
trouver toute toute une série de travaux
à la fois universitaire ce qu'on appelle
la littérature grise qui n'est pas
forcément d'un accès facile et puis
aussi bah les toutes les les articles et
les les publication des bien sûr des
gens du centre mais de tous les
chercheurs dans notre domaine et moi ce
que j'aime aimerait bien c'est que aussi
bien à valpariso qu'à Moscou ou que
Johannesbourg quelqu'un qui a envie de
faire un travail en histoire culturel ce
disent qu'il a peut-être à passer par
notre base de données par notre site
pour euh démarrer ses recherches je vais
donner quelques chiffres tout de même
pour ce centre d'histoire culturelle 37
enseignants chercheurs statutaires 40
enseignants chercheurs associés 37
chercheurs associés quatre titulaires de
contrracts doctoraux 60 doctorants 70
publications collectives euh tous ces
chiffres au milieu de tous ces chiffres
ça veut dire véritablement quelque chose
ils sont représentatifs vous pesez
véritablement sur la recherche
aujourd'hui je pense et notamment dans
dans tous les chiffres que vous avez
cité un j'aimerais mettre en avant c'est
nos 60 doctorants parce que c'est
vraiment la richesse d'un laboratoire
d'université c'est les doctorants c'est
les chercheurs de demain et de ce point
de vue-là le fait qu'on attire des
chercheurs un petit peu de toute la
France que des gens se disent quand je
veux faire une thèse sur les médias ou
sur l'histoire du livre ou sur les
relations culturelles internationales il
faut que je vienne à Saint-Quentin ça
c'est quand même la reconnaissance
majeure et ça me semble être vraiment la
richesse majeure du centre ce sont les
docteurs qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour les 20 prochaines années
euh bah écoutez de continuer à grandir
de rester quand même ce qu'on est et
puis de de garder ce lien qu'on a très
fort avec le territoire avec la ville de
Saint-Quentin parce que c'est quand même
si on a un centre d'histoire culturel
c'est peut-être aussi parce que
Saint-Quentin s'est construit sur la
culture et je pense que ce qu'on a fait
là on n'urait pas pu faire le faire dans
un autre cadre donc de ce point de
vue-là peut-être grandir avoir un renom
international mais rester aussi
intimement lié à la ville de
saint-quantin merci jean-claudon donc
direct adjoint du Centre d'histoire
culturelle des sociétés contemporaines
professeur en histoire je le reprécise
vous m'excuserez pour l'erreur du début
et le centre qui Fa donc ses 20 ans bon
anniversaire donc à vous ces de saisons
la patinoire de Versailles a repris du
service une patinoire écologique dotée
d'une surface synthétique qui fonctionne
sans Z ni électricité elle est installée
devant l'hôtel de ville c'est jusqu'au 6
janvier les précisions avec Valérie
oribo glissé déraper chuter pour la plus
grande joie des petits mais aussi des
grands une patinoire en plein air a pris
place devant l'Hôtel de Ville de
Versailles pour la 4e année consécutive
une patinoire particulière elle est
écologique elle fonctionne sans eau sans
électricité et les plaques de
polyoléphine peuvent être réutilisées
plusieurs fois c'est autolubrifié donc
on a quand même pas encore tout à fait
la qualité de la vraie glace mais ça
commence à rapprocher et comme nous
avons deux affuteuses sur place qui nous
permet de affuter les patins
relativement tout le temps hein on a
quand même qui reste très correct par
rapport à la vraie glace faut quand même
un petit temps d'adaptation parce que
j'ai vraiment pas l'habitude de faire de
la patinoire
synthétique moins dur que la glace
véritable en cas de chute mais aussi
sans humidité on n risque pas d'être
mouillé et d'attraper froid c'est
excellent c'est un peu différent du
patin ordinaire c'est un peu faut un
petit temps d' d'adaptation voilà mais
c'est marrant et pour reprendre des
forces gaufre crêpes et boissons chaudes
régalent les visiteurs c'est génial
c'est super les enfants s'amusent bien
et on passe un très bon moment on a
l'impression d'être en vacances avant
l'heure chaque année entre 5000 et 6000
patineurs viennent s'exercer sur la
patinoire éphémère qui restera ouverte
jusqu'au 6
janvier